un paso más hacia el envío de tanques
leopardo durante una rueda de prensa
conjunta con el jefe de la otan el
ministro de defensa alemán animó a los
países que poseen estos tanques a
empezar a entrenar las fuerzas
ucranianas a usarlos insinuando que
Berlín estaría cerca de dar luz verde al
permiso para reexportar los vehículos
militares
he animado expresamente a los países
socios que tienen tanques leopard listos
para ser desplegados a que formen a las
fuerzas ucranianas en estos tanques
Polonia dijo esperar la respuesta pronto
y pidió a Alemania Que aumente su apoyo
militar a Ucrania
Alemania es el país más grande y debe
hacer una enorme contribución a esta
coalición conjunta de países que ayudan
a Ucrania hemos presentado esta
solicitud y esperamos una pronta
respuesta
por supuesto ya estamos entrenando a
soldados ucranianos en Polonia otros
países también lo están haciendo y
haciéndolo
sin embargo el ministro de defensa
alemán recordó que su país se encuentra
en las tres naciones que han
proporcionado mayor ayuda económica
Alemania ya ha gastado en total más de
3.300 millones de euros solo Reino Unido
está en el mismo orden de magnitud
aparte de Estados Unidos esto muestra
claramente lo grande que es el
compromiso de Alemania además de todo el
compromiso humanitario y otras ayudas
Alemania sigue siendo tímida sobre la
cuestión de mandar o no tanques modernos
a Ucrania el país está dividido
internamente sobre la cuestión de
comprometerse más directamente en la
guerra en Ucrania por su lado el
portavoz del crimen dijo que tales
entregas dejarían una huella indeleble
en las relaciones ruales